Irellars Granbahamal tona galtoeba rilex.
He had gone insane.
Yes, well…
Japanese?
Sorry about that.
I just came back from spending
17 years in Granbahamal.
Let's check your temperature.
Zalbe madira kolstonam kolstonam.
Isn't that right?
Del storba tona rabelt gal.
All right, see you during the next round.
You must be Takafumi, my sister's kid.
You've grown up.
Where is everyone?
After you fell into a coma,
the family fought bitterly over
what to do with you until it fell apart.
Honestly speaking,
my mom would rather not see you.
MY FAMILY FELL APART
DUE TO FIGHTING OVER ME
Icuras cuora.
Well then,
let me prove to you that
I lived in another world.
What? No, thanks.
War-grent seld.
SPRING WATER
What?
War-grent magna!
War-grent rald!
-This is hard to watch…
-War-grent neld!
War-grent gad!
War-grent pad!
-You know…
-War-grent larch!
…the economic decline
has been hard on me, too.
I work part-time to support myself.
I brought papers for you to apply
for self-reliance support and whatnot.
Wind, lift!
No way!
Wind, return.
Japanese works in this world.